are we live
[Music]
good morning everybody and welcome to
the uh
plans committee for the third of
february friday the year started to fly
by already yeah um
first day one
first item on the agenda is to introduce
the committee over here
and the officers and i'll start with
myself
i'm councillor chris leather and i
represent northern
council pete watson and i represent
brody
um
[Music]
thank you and i'll start with the
offices
on my left good morning members one
members of public my name is john
harrington and i'm a planning manager
good morning my name
is district council
good morning my name is
[Music]
services
good morning i'm kirsty brown and i'm
democratic services officer
michael newton from denver islands
tracy
management
lovely thank you that's
all who are present
in an official capacity this morning
well item one on the agenda
well just one thing there is a
fire alarm test due about 11 o'clock
yeah but we don't have to leave it it's
just a test to be about right but if
it's definite as we'll have to just
perhaps hang on for a minute or two
[Music]
not
yet okay
we'll move on then there is one on the
agenda's apologies for absence
page two on the agenda is the
minutes of the meeting held on the 12th
of january
of january pages 5 to 15
and i've got one
my counselor lobster pointed out on page
14. the vote there shows two abstentions
councillor brown and council craig i
think they and yet the report says
to against i think that should be
against
that was
recorded or shown as abstain but it was
two votes against the car park at
toronto
yeah it actually says the vote is 7.2
again
the crossing the wrong
council craig you were against that yeah
so that should show in certain
abstentions that should show
again
[Music]
[Music]
boat castle watson left a room which
pays me out 11 yeah
i didn't i didn't leave that was the
vote to extend the meeting past three
hours getting a cup of coffee okay
all right
um yeah so could we just commend that
i was here
okay
well your vote was taken to extend
yeah
yeah okay
oh yeah
[Music]
thank you
item 3 on the agenda is declarations of
interest
members with interest to declare
should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the action is being
considered
elected members of denver county council
and town and parish councils
who've considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council hold a personal interest and are
deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not find the members concerned
who consider the application afresh
and i often mention here that a lot of
information on applications comes in at
the last minute
then
even after parish and general councils
have considered application
right item four on the agenda is the
agreement between parts one and two
there is no part two
item five is urgent matters the language
of masses
item six is public participation
[Applause]
[Music]
participation
[Music]
public speaking at the plans committee
or who attend the plans committee
uh expected to give a fair hearing
to uninterrupted hearing to the planning
office they give in their report
and to all those listed to speak and to
the planning committee members when they
begin their consideration
and
for speaking speakers this morning we've
got
so they haven't
got one two
three speakers to everts enrolled
two against and one in support
for the duckhaven step one we've got
force one two three five speakers
including the board member council of
pennington
two against two in support and award
member
and then finally for chichester way
application
council of laws the ward member will be
speaking to them
so that's the speakers for this movie
right item seven on the agenda is
applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports
are correct correct as of the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates that
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
and our first application this morning
is seven a
you know planning officer angela matassa
it's on page 16 to 21 of europe
[Music]
i'm here to present the application for
a retrospective
balcony elected to the northern
elevation and the installation of the
single window to the west elevation
um which seeks to vary a previous plan
commission
reference there one slash 1179
of
[Music]
the plan before you shows the location
of the site in relation to chichester
way it's situated in westwood home
the image to the right-hand side shows
an aerial image of the approximate
boundary of the site and the location
panel so that shows more detailed
orientation of the site
plans before you show the approved
elevations from the previous plan
commission
in 2019
the elevations before you show the
proposed balcony and the alteration to
the western elevation and the single
roof lights window
the slide before he shows the previously
approved floor plans
and proposed balcony
the image performance shows the
principal elevation of these
of 11
way with the previously approved
extension
as
partly
completed um this slide before you show
the principal elevations of uh number 11
and number 12 which is away from the
entrance of the private drive
leading to the properties
there's another
image of the principal relations of both
properties
so the views
within the images before you show the
balcony
uh evolation towards
uh number 12 which is away
and also from the existing colored
terraced area which was part of the
original dwelling
the images before you show from the
front of number 12 just away looking
towards number 11.
and here's a further image from the
front of their number 12 chichester way
looking towards the
existing west elevation
and outside today
material planning considerations before
you are the principal development which
is deemed
[Music]
appearance the neighbour in the meeting
which is set out
to deem to not result in any significant
arms and labour properties as detailed
in the officer's report
highways and provisional parking and
insight and ecology
the recommendations for this application
is being approved and i'll talk about
the chairman
[Music]
thank you angelo
one speaker to this application because
it was called by
councillor laws who is a member for
westwood hall
it's important that we view this
uh in the round to start with
the
application for the extension previous
extension
there were a lot of negotiations to
bring it back to meters
bank commissioners agreed and that now
we're subject to a retrospective
application
which brought the property forward again
it was considered to be too much massing
to start with
the issue of the
balcony in this application is that
because of the
massing of building the balcony is
considered a very small extension
and it seems to me
yes
it's wrong
i know planning law allows it
but norman felt strongly against it if
you go and look at the property look at
that image you can see that the
neighbor's property is looking straight
along this balcony
if minded to grant it please ensure that
there is adequate screening
um
[Music]
it's just a story of two or three
retrospective applications leading to
this
and it's the percentage that is to
reduce the concerns
thank you chad
thank you counselors
[Music]
like
the last of the speakers to this
application
could i just ask andrew
we're talking about the balkan on the
front aren't we yes that's what the
privilege is screaming to the side
correct
i
[Music]
these
double doors are with the julia bulk in
it there's no balcony to be erected
there isn't it
so the principal elevation is where the
outcome will be elected on the previous
planning permission it was designed with
the juliet's balcony and so
on the left there
[Music]
so there is a juliet balcony that's
already had planned improvement subject
to this
application that's solely the back
to the right hand side here
and then the other question i've got is
increase the width of the meter of that
extension correct so and you've got the
the access to the rear of the problem
there there was the constraints access
to the side
which you can see
it's blurred obviously but that's
[Music]
yeah
if you look at
condition two
that states that
there has to be a 1.7 meter
uh screening
in
obscure class
and as far as i'm concerned
to be quite honest i think this is all
right
um and i'm i'm amounting to my mind to
go with it and in fact i'll propose it
i've just got one one question for it's
not a question really it's an
observation
we're only really literally talking
about an extra one meter because the
extension was grounded under permitted
development right so we're only talking
an extra one b
correct yeah
so i will
second council watson's recommendation
[Music]
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
our next application
is on pages 20
22-87
of your agenda
and that planning officer
[Music]
application reference 1-8926
[Music]
slash 2020 aotn
this is a major outline planning
application with all matters reserved
access
for the election of up to 290 dwellings
and associated infrastructure around
norfolk function road in business
so there's just a few verbal updates
since the publication of the officer's
report
members will
have seen and witnessed that the agent
has produced a wooden management
strategy which has been sent to members
and has also been
linked to the council's website
um it is important to know that this is
not new information the agent has
provided a summary sheet of already
submitted information and details and
commitments that are secured by planning
conditions
in respectful woodland management plan
um so there has also been two further
representations received the publication
of this report one of the
representations makes comments on the
woodland management strategy and advises
that
they have significant misgivings about
the aspects of the proposed management
of woodland
in particular the inadequacy of the
proposed passive measures
um and they have some
um eventually sort of they're very
worried about the sensitive area
particularly
territory
um and there's also been another further
representation which objects the
application as in their view that
business site is not suitable for to be
built on um i think both of those
representations they are sort of covered
in this report
um
as members um would have listened to my
previous presentation last committee i'm
um
i and they've also attended a very
detailed site visit i will try and keep
the presentation more succinct um but
obviously i do need to go through the
presentation again just to read some of
those
site in the members
[Music]
um so just moving on to the presentation
so this is a location plan with the site
outlined in red and blue
as a whole the site is 18.87 hectares in
size and comprises of three agricultural
fields and the southern part of the four
agricultural fields
um
yeah next slide so the site and this is
sort of a more detailed location plan
with the site outlined in red this
demonstrates a relationship on the site
um which sits to the east of the built
form of biddeford
and shows around the very boundaries so
to the south is average road to the east
is osborne lane to the northern road and
to the west the a39 and the a39 viaduct
next slide
so this is an aerial image from the site
outlined in red um as members will be
aware from the virtual side visit there
is a central area of woodlands with
battersville wood which has a woodland
teepee on it
there is also two watercourses running
through the site which run southwards
into perennial valley um and the
scientists you'll see is predominantly
agricultural land with which hedge fund
boundaries of mature trees
the next slide just to provide um
memphis with the strategic context again
this is an extract from the north
evidence local plan policies map the
biddeford
the site to the west of the town um
is the west in the town this light is
actually indicating with an orange arrow
so this is just reminding how the site
fits in with the context of the
strategic center of biddeford
um the next slide
this is just slightly focusing on the
site and again the the site is indicated
in the orange area the black line is the
development boundary for the biddeford
so you can see the site is outside of
the development boundary but the slider
joins the development boundary to the
south and east
and to the south of the site is
annotated on the purple hatchling being
policy bit 01 which is the allocated
site for bit of the urban extension of
approximately 71 hectares
the next slide say this is just a
development framework so just going to
before going
more into depth in this presentation i
just wanted to remind members of what
the proposal includes so it is an
outline application but there has been
an illustrative development plan
to demonstrate how the scheme could be
accommodated on site um so this is not
for determination this is just
illustrative
um so this is a major outline planning
application we've all made matters
deserved other than access for up to 290
dwellings including 15 affordable
housing 11.7 hectares of informal and
formal open space including unique
synthetic features including four
attenuation projects
access is for detailed consideration at
this stage and the proposal includes two
new vehicle access points from average
road indicated in the two arrows of the
plan
the hedge along the southern boundary is
proposed to be translocated to provide a
freely to shared footway cycleway along
the actual road frontage to allow
connectivity with silicon
so i'm just going to go to some photos
of the site again i'll try and be very
quick because i know we've had a very
detailed site visit so this is the
southern boundary of the site this is
the photo showing the street level of
addiction road to the south members will
recall a video with the road frontage
and this is where the two bigger access
points are to be located and also the
complacent obviously includes that hedge
being translocated back to provide a
three liter footwear cycle right along
albertson road to provide that
pedestrian connectivity
so next slide so it has been agreed to
seven county accounts
[Music]
[Music]
cyclist
and next slide this is the top of
voiceball play and the proposal also
includes the widening of this section of
the footweight two meters to the
existing crossing again to provide that
pedestrian connectivity and linkages to
the site to benefit
um so just going on to some photos on
the site this is the southern boundary
of the site this is the hedge which is
to be translocated and to provide the
two access points
next slide this is taking looking south
west boundary of the site and the white
building in the distance is lower
windsword court which is in a
third-party aid ship um and there are a
number of dwellings and will be in that
third party ownership
this is just slightly zoomed in of the
southwest boundary again showing the
dwelling today there's lower whispered
court which is situated at the southwest
boundary of the site and the photo also
shows the western boundary the site
along the head behind the hedgerows the
so this photo is looking at the western
boundary to the site to the left as far
as norwood
and this is another photo
of the eastern boundary the white
dwelling is lower windspit cottage which
again is within their classionship
the next slide is the eastern boundary
of the site so the hedge bank is behind
those osmond lane and as you can see
that red eastern residential
edge of biddeford
with the existing weddings and
londonderry just popping through
and just another facial
and again there's just a flat eastern
boundary
the next slide
this is looking to the west of the site
with the a39 viaduct in the background
and the next slide is just showing you
one of the waterfalls is running through
the site
and the next slide is a photo or badges
hill wood which um as mentioned of
course 0.45 hectares of woodland um
during the course of the application the
majority of the woodland will be
accessible for public access but will be
managed and there is a proposed buffer
around the woodland protection which
we'll be showing later on in the
presentation
as members recall independent apologies
has been viewed in scrutinizing quality
matters relating to this planning
application
so the next slide is just another face
with woodland looking to the south
and the next slide is another photo this
is the western section of the site and
you can see the london jury estate there
and next slide
is a spatial north west corner of the
site which is left you can see the
western boundary and you can see the a39
a39 viaduct
and then just another photo
from the western section showing
existing
[Music]
from abortion rate
in the next slide so an lbia has been
submitted which shows photo montages
with various viewpoints surrounding the
site
the next few faces show photo montages
from the existing buildings um so taking
from the built form a bit of food from
the londonderry state to the east of the
site
so the next slide shows the top base has
been taken from valve away which
indicates the site of the black arrow
and the possum coach demonstrates the
sight from the open space to the east of
sandbridge park
and the next slide with the chopped
photo is from the open space and south
of warren view and the bottom fascia is
taken from the open space north quarry
close
and then the next photo is from the
green space in londonderry estate
and the next slide so the top photo is
from the open space to the west of lane
field and the bottom facial is filled
towards the site from average range
now the next slide
is another series of photos shown from
the lbia images and these are from
viewpoints slightly further along from
away from the north and west of the site
so the next side this view
towards the side so that's this is from
within the grounds of kenwood castle
um this baby the next phase show is from
the east towards the site from the city
of the white house across
and the next space who looks south west
towards the site and that's from the
lane east of the a39 viaduct
and the next slide is the view of these
sites from the eastern side from the
edge of action
and the next slide this is standing to
the north of the site from the public
footpath looking
looking forward top photo shows onto the
site outlined in red just remember to
have a better understanding of how that
fits in with that sort of surrounding
landscape
um in terms of submitted lbia in support
of the application
members will recall from my last
presentation from the report it has been
reviewed by the independent landscape
officer the comments of the landscape
officer reviewing it um it's been set
out in full in your reports and i'm sure
you've read these from the conclusion
comments that there is some disagreement
with the main conclusion from the
subject of lvia
and the landscape officer views that
there would be
the proposal would result in change the
landscape character site christine
important to note
um so the next slide moves on to a plan
of the surrounding landscape
designations
so the site is annotated in red to the
middle of the side the site itself is
not covered by any statutory or
non-statutory designations for landscape
cultural character
the north seven aomb is approximately
800 metres to the east the site is
indicated as an orange dotted line
there are 17 listed buildings in the
study area which has been included on
the planet
and kenwood castle and governor castle
and they painted the northern site
indication orange night annotation
the council's conservation officer has
been consulted on this application and
has raised no objections
the county council senior historic
environment officer has been consulted
to advise
that previous support
[Music]
you still hear me yeah apparently i had
advised that previous archaeological
field elevation has demonstrated the
presence of archaeological features
across the site these features however
are not of such significance that they
should be preserved in situ
um the impact of the development however
should be mitigated by a program of
archaeological works and that is
attaching a brief medicine commission
so just go back to the site of some of
the technical highway drawings which
obviously is a matter for consideration
um
next slide
[Music]
as previously indicated highway is a
detailed consideration stager outline
introducing this this size indicates the
two vehicle access points from adoption
road and that three meter um shared
which way to allow that connectivity to
be in biddeford
the next slide just shows the widening
of the footweight of the northern uh
side of ashton road between osborne lane
and lane in field to two meters
um mike nicole is here as a highway
engineer if there are any questions in
terms of highway
masses
so the next slide
um is the battersville wood which is an
important element of this application
but to the center of the site is badges
hillwood which is designated as another
site of wildlife interests
the wood is approximately 0.45
collectors which have said to you and
has priced as retained in moderate
condition
the woodland is to be retained as part
of the proposal
during the course of the application the
ancient woodland specialist from
denver's university working center has
surveyed the woodland and confirms that
part of the woodland known as
compartment two which is shown on that
plan
should be treated as provisional ancient
woodland
the proposal would not result in the
direct loss of woodland however without
litigation there would be some impact it
is proposed that the woodland management
clients will be adopted as part of the
scheme and move from part of the
landscape and ecological management plan
to be submitted and approved at reserve
matters
so the next side there is a tree
preservation order which applies to the
trees present within the bachelor
woodland position essentially within the
site this is hatched in green to the
left showing the full extension of that
gpa
the next slide shows a tree pretention
plan an agricultural assessment has been
submitted which includes the only tree
covered to be removed will be a small
number of trees identified as g6 located
between the lower minus for cottage to
allow the construction of the linking
access
additionally the southern boundary hedge
bank is to be translocated northwards to
allow that widening of the carriageway
[Music]
none of the trees from the tree
preservation order are to be affected by
the proposals
so the next slide is a green
infrastructure plan again this is only
an outline application so this is not
the determination today but is an
indication of what green infrastructure
could be provided on site
and the next slide is a drainage plan so
the majority of the site falls within
fuzz zone one
however the chemistry runs along south
to north to the middle site which has an
associated area that has risk flooding
which is designated by say two and three
the submitted risk assessment confirms
that a sequential approach will be taken
the area development will all be within
plus zone one
and as i said previously on the next
slide there are two watercourses which
run through ranchersville wood
waterfalls one enters into the culver
into the south of amateur road
and the next slide shows the proposed
surface water drainage strategy
comprises all four attenuation basins
which have been indicated on this plan
the site lies within a critical drainage
area which means that more stringent
standards need to be adhered to in terms
of drainage calculations
the aging strategy is wholly in line
with these student standards and has
been accepted by the technical risk
engineer at denver county council
uh the next slide shows the foul
drainage is to be disposed in with an
existing public sewer southwest water
have raised no objections
and confirmed that any improvement
considered necessary will be undertaken
by themselves to ensure the development
can be adequately drained
so the next slide again is just an
illustrative master plan it's not for
determination today it demonstrates how
the proposal could be developed to
accommodate up to 290 dwellings
so now let's go on to the planning
considerations which as you will see
detailed in your report just as a
summary the principle of development
as a council we are not able to
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply currently so the determination
must be based on the tilted balance
which is the presumption in favor of
sustainable development unless the harm
attached to the proposal would
significantly and demonstrately outweigh
the benefits when investigates policies
in the framework taken as a whole
landscaping character visual impact the
site is not covered by any statutory or
non-statutory landscape character or
quality designations
as members have seen from the site visit
the site has a very top topography and
is very steeply sloping in spaces and
undulating in others the site is well
contained by mature hedgerows and tree
belts with existing road lanes forming
defensible boundaries
an lbi was submitted lbia was submitted
in support of the application
the lbia has been independently reviewed
by an independent landscape officer and
then conclusions are set out in their
approach
in summary she considers there would be
some moderate to substantial landscape
change and she does disagree with some
of the extent of the conclusions of the
lbia
and concerns there would be a residual
nonspeaking visual harm
it is identified that the proposal will
result in landscape change as such i
think i want to make clear to members
there would be some conflict policy
objectives set out in policy st4g and
dfmoa
to conserve the serve and enhance the
local distinctions of the landscape
properties
but as of course it is noticed that
parts of the site can be seen in the
context of the built form as we've seen
from this presentation
and the reserve massive application will
secure mitigation measures
so heritage and archaeology there are no
designated heritage assets within the
site boundary
the council's conservation officer has
no objections the council's senior
historic officers also advise that the
archaeological features are not six
significant that they need to be
preserved this issue
presidential immunity at outlying stage
it is not considered the phrase
development resulting powerful impact on
residential neighbours of nato
properties
highways um as you see this is
included as access to detail
consideration at this stage
and highway authorities raised no
objections as i said might move newton
from highways is here if members have
any questions about some highways
floodplain skin drainage the special
approach will be taken to the
development site to ensure that it's
only located in first day one
the proposed surface water drainage
actually comprises of four attenuation
funds
seven county council blood risk
engineering has specialised the
proposals and believes they are entirely
important with our local guidance studs
for general guidance as well as national
guidance
the concerns raised by third parties are
noted however technical quantities are
advising the local planning authority
that the proposed provisions for
drainage on the site are technically
acceptable
ecology and diversity
the economy aspect of the site has been
looked at in huge detail over the course
of the year while this application has
been considered there are a number of
ecology reports and there's a robust
evidence base assessing
important features identified on the
site
um it has been reviewed by an excellent
apologist and she is happy providing the
proposed education measures secured
through appropriately where the
conditions the proposals will meet local
and national policy and legislation
the biodiversity gain is indicative um
but it is being proposed as a 23 23
percent due to the extensive green space
and mitigation enhancement measures
proposed breaches for wood
viability and sexual inertia this
application has been supported by a
viability appraisal and this has been
externally reviewed by the district
foundation
the conclusion the district value
officer of the scheme is not financially
viable when contributing planning
commission requirements including 30
housing
the scheme is able to provide 15
affordable housing so that would provide
44 affordable units on this site
along with all the other required
section 106
[Music]
contributions planning balance in
conclusion as discussed the labour
planning authority cannot currently
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply
so in this incident the teacher's
tilting balance would need to be applied
the proposal would provide a significant
contribution up to 290 dwellings towards
local housing supply on a site which
broadens the strategic centre of
biddeford
it should be provoked it knows that the
proposal includes a range of benefits
and the conclusions of open space
and 44 units and
financial contributions towards
infrastructure such as health facilities
and education proficient
returning to the adverse impact as
discussed earlier the proposed
development will change the character of
the site and the impact of development
would be adverse in landscape terms
however it is recognised that mitigation
measures exist which reduce these
impacts over time beyond the local
context but they don't entirely negate
them
so um this is an unbalanced decision
where the benefits and halves have been
addressed in this presentation and it is
your officer's consideration that the
benefits of the proposal outweigh the
half when assessed against policies in
the local plan and the mppf as a whole
therefore there is a recommendation of
approval which is made with the
imposition of conditions and sexual one
and six obligations
thank you i hope that was a bit more
sustainable
thank you very much tracy for that thank
you
right our first speaker um speaking
against the application is philipp
morrow
i believe he's got three sides
[Music]
okay let's just make sure this is
working yeah yeah
i'm a 40-year resident of the area and
warden of the nature reserve opposite
this site at godbreak
now tdc have recognized a climate
emergency but not the existing and very
real biodiversity emergency
kenwood valley ecosystem as a whole is a
fragile entity depending on a delicate
balance between many different elements
it needs to be big enough to support all
those different elements
it's a bit like a large picture which
looks wonderful but if you cut it up
into lots of little pieces
you're left with nothing they're useless
straps of paper
the description of the valley and the
formal reports has shown real ignorance
of the valley
we have 25-year records called
godbrassite and kenwood site and we were
never consulted never visited and none
of those photos showing the landscape
character
are taken within the valley they're all
taken outside or on the site
now 35 years ago gobbler had limited
ecological value
since then hard work
and time has transformed it to near sssi
in value
in the 1980s the batch of wood sites had
real ecological value
damp meadows ancient woodland
[Music]
thriving
wildlife
dumping of soil and uncontrolled grazing
diminished its value and caused
regular flooding in the valley below
however the lack of human interference
has allowed badges to thrive
and even more important that large area
of unimproved grassland provides vital
paradigms mammals especially bats
and birds
that exist within the area
it's exactly the type of site that
government policy now says should be
reverting to nature under the
environmental land management scheme
if this was done there'd be major
synergistic benefits to godbra and
kenworth nature reserve
in contrast if you go ahead and approve
this project there is a tenure a tenuous
10 increase in biodiversity based on a
theoretical model which ignores the
harsh conditions in the valley
and no practical plan to see it through
now if we can show the slides please of
the next one
this is a less professional version but
it shows the green in the middle
is
the godbros site
the
purple sites are all those sites that
have been
cleared for planning or
things have been built on over the 35
years we've built up the dog recite
and you can see where it came with
nature reserving at the is
on the right hand side the important
thing is that that badger wood site
opposite our site is the only area left
for livestock to feed it
we've gone to the next slide
this is a view from most probably the
best butterfly slope in this area in the
middle of our site looking
across those fields
are regularly used by livestock from
the bottom of the valley
our reserve and kenwood reserves
[Music]
surely the promise of 44 affordable
homes which may or may not be built and
may or may not be affordable by local
people
the
the price of sacrificing
our nature reserve because without that
land for animals to feed on
our 35 years effort building up god
breath
is in danger
thank you thank you mr marvel
our next speaker against this
application is patricia
[Music]
clarke when you're settled you also have
three minutes to
present your case thank you
i have lived in our londonderry farm
estate for 38 years
which is very close to this proposed
development
so today
i want to speak about this amendment
which will include budgeting wood and
give the public access
having read the committee report dated
12th of january
it states that these woods are
designated as a woodland priority
habitat and as a site of nature
conservation interest the woodland trust
campaign is also beginning to have these
woods put on the ancient woodland
inventory
which tells me how important these woods
are and why they should be protected
also they are almost in the center of
the unesco biosphere in north dakota
and in an area
designated as a transition zone
when i first became aware that the
public were going to be given access to
these woods i was horrified
my first thought being what would happen
to all wildlife but also what will
happen to the woodland itself
on londonderry farm state there's a deep
ravine with many trees and an abundance
of wildlife
very similar to budget hill wood
this is fenced off but residents still
dump their garden waste another rubbish
into
injury
once i even saw a jar full of old engine
oil lying in the grass
when my husband and i go out walking we
usually walk through the children's play
area at the southern end of this review
and we often see empty cans and beer
bottles lying around which must have
been thrown away by children or
teenagers as adults would be drinking at
home
also a problem in this play are dog
walkers who do not pick up after the
dance
once we saw dog pooch's yards from one
of the two dog bins provided plus the
moor that had been picked up but the bag
had been discarded
so if this happens in the children's
play area it's bound to happen in these
woods including the stream which runs
through it
the applicants say that they intend to
put up signs saying please keep your dog
on the lead
but we all know that there are some dog
owners who won't keep their dogs on a
lead despite these signs
there are also children who will want to
blame these woods including stream but
who could cause a lot of harm even
though it would probably be
unintentional
the applicants state that these woods
can be protected by a woodland
management plan but who will pay for
this how long will it be in existence
for and will it stop irresponsible
behavior i don't think so
lastly we all have one last chance to
say
what is left of this beautiful valley
the future generations to mature
because once it's gone it's not going
back
thank you thank you
our next speaker in support of the
application is stuart carl
are you a few minutes to address the
committed
um thank you very much and thank you
very much again memphis for an
opportunity to speak to you um i
listened to the concerns that you raised
at the previous meeting and i wanted to
present to you the management strategy
note to demonstrate how the wooden
little site will be managed and accessed
through planning commission grants
um on the site are protected by a tree
protection order there is currently no
active management of the woodland and
it's through this planning application
this can be effectively done
um the note that i sent you and it's
available to members of the public and
on the council's website and there's a
visual summary of the reports the
community planning application and
associate associated panel conditions so
i hope that's been helpful to you
and these show how new fencing head
banks will protect sensitive areas as
well as signage and interpretation
boards provided throughout the woodland
for essence to understand and enjoy its
provision
and new planting will help retain these
areas the area throughout the woodlands
currently subject to soil erosion given
there's no active management a new plant
we will help to bind that soil together
prevent existing trees from falling and
as the officer outlines this end this
ends up resulting in net gains and
biodiversity
and as there is currently no public
access to this area this is opportunity
to connect new existing residents of
biddeford to this green source green
resource for generations to come and
allow it to be managed in an effective
and proper way
and the science sorry the site is in
compliance with the spatial strategy for
courage it will deliver a multitude of
benefits that set up a case officer
empirical and her presentations
i've respectfully asked you to consider
again again in your deliberations and
see how this development can connect
people with nature in an effective
appropriate and managed way in
compliance with your special strategies
for the area thank you
thank you thank you
mr carl
[Music]
right that's um
that's the last speaker
and councillor christie came in once the
presentation started and not able to
speak this morning
i must apologize for that but can i ask
i mean i have a real sense of do you do
that i hadn't heard anything new from
the officer i'm sorry i've already heard
it
so i'm how have i not heard the debate
there were updates from the officer that
you weren't
that she gave me for giving up a
presentation that you weren't here for
cancer so i'm not allowed to vote no
sorry
[Music]
i'm allowed to speak though no
no
can't take part in the debate
[Music]
i've had no agenda for this reason
did anyone else get a paper agenda
i haven't had one
that's why i didn't realize it was on
this morning
i've got all my paperwork but i've had
no agenda for this
all i've had is the um extra bit for
that ones
well it went back to the email
the agenda went touching the email i
haven't had the paper again i'm sorry
but sometimes my my email's been playing
up just recently all right and
[Music]
because i know this application has been
something that you've
spoken on and
been close to your heart as a board
member
for many years
so i won't stop the ball rolling on this
this morning because i'm gonna move for
refusal on it
um
the balance the tilted balance in favor
of sustainable development
is not overwritten if it means the
destruction
of ancient woodland and biodiversity
which this undoubtedly would
[Music]
and i think the
virtual senate visit we had really
didn't
do justice to the topography of that
site and exactly
what it looks like when you visit it so
i went and looked at it i do know the
area rather than
but there's no doubt in my mind
that if this application is improved it
will destroy that ancient woodland it
will destroy a lot of the hedges in the
area the biodiversity the ecological
value of that area will be
obliterated eventually because you
cannot open those ancient woodlands up
to the public
and expect them to remain the same in
the wildlife to remain there the same
and you can't surround that with a
housing estate of up to 290 houses
and not change the whole thing and
that's in the report as well
and
the county landscape officer for me
makes a very prescient report when they
speak about
the resulting substantial change to the
strongly rolling topography
predominantly pastoral land use and
attractiveness of the landscape
provided by police in composition of
woodland and farmland
such landscape change would have a
localized moderate to substantial
adverse effect on biddeford's beautiful
countryside
setting as perceived by people
particularly those looking out from the
residential areas
and associating public realm on the
western edge of bitterly
however residual and the adverse
landscape and visual effects would be
unavoidable with greater impact
resulting from development within the
higher more visually sensitive western
parts of the site and immediately
adjacent to the hedgerow board in
osborne lane there is
the tilted balance does not negate our
planet as we all know planning policies
in the north end
and local plan
and i've
heard the debate from others but i've
got
listed here all the policies that this
is contrary to
if it's allowed
and the reasons why it's sponsored
but i'll leave it at that center and ask
anybody else
counselor
[Music]
we all know that since the girl with a
pill
no green areas is is safe we're told
that um we can't supply a five-year by
the time and that's opened this area to
developers to come in and put their
application forward however special it
is whether it's in the local plan or
outside
we need houses as everything we said
years ago build field bills but we need
houses for local people
and this only supplies
a half of the 30 percent
not enough in my estimation
i want to worry about the effects of
climate change i know the advocate has
put forward measures
to deal with this
but i was around i did see the floods
staring all down and i do feel whatever
measures have put in place
we're not able to control climate change
at the moment it changes from day to day
and we could have tremendous storms
which will actually destroy that area
again so for me children it should be
used as well
thank you
i wanted to do a second devotion to
refuse um i think there are overwhelming
um arguments against the development
and i didn't see that the only thing
that um members found in failure
was the 44
social housing affordable
affordable housing
well i i personally
thought then and think now that it's the
wrong place for social housing
it's actually stuck out on a limb
there's no shop there's no julius school
uh there's very few buses
anybody living on this new estate would
have to have a car beach
and so we're talking about 290 houses
you know we're talking over 500 nearly
600 cars
and
that that's my first point i don't think
it is the right place for social housing
much as i want i want social housing for
benefit more than anybody but it's not
the right place for it so if that is the
only bonus that we have from that i
don't think with the roman bonus the
people in londonderry are still waiting
for the community center and the shop
that was promised to them when it was
built
you know i don't i can't remember when
it was built but many years ago
so it's not the right side to social
housing so then we go to the woodland
the wooden report
i thought it was
put up a load of pathetic
to protect special areas who's going to
maintain those fences
who's going to pay for all this
i mean you just said there will be a
management plan there'll be a friend of
friends of badger
but
is it going to go on to the
the people that live there are they
paying for the management plan or they
they're just maybe hoping that there's a
town council or some
you know local people will take on the
management place
so i don't think that's workable for a
start and we we know on business town
council how much it costs to feed board
with them
and it's often a problem because it's
very expensive to keep witness
but and then we come to the wildlife i
think he's destructive of the wildlife
and the ecology i think when the rain is
when it's concreted over with roads and
houses there'll be more rain it will be
a knock on effect in kevin's valley with
the excess water
um
i think
under the
visibility because it's a lovely valley
you can see it from so many different
areas it's not just from the people
living next door but from from all
around and especially from the main road
people driving up that road will look at
movement and instead of seeing a
beautiful valley with a woodland and a
stream they will see a housing stain and
they will think if they drive past but
if it is like every other place um it's
just a large town we know we haven't got
the facilities we haven't got the
schools and the doctors peter christie
pointed out last time we haven't got the
schools
it look i really i feel very strongly
about this any planning application that
we've had before us
that this is probably one of the little
bits of benefit that's beautiful to look
at
and we should be doing everything we can
to keep it
and not allowing it just to be another
housing development
and i would just strongly support that
we would go for refusal
thank you
thank you councilman
yeah well i'm afraid i must
disagree with the previous speakers um i
know
we discussed fully last week about the
viability appraisal and i know
myself included disappointed that that
has been reduced to 50 percent
affordable
um which
related to 44 dwellings um and we looked
closely at what they included abnormal
costs and i mean there was a ridiculous
under sixty thousand six hundred and
forty four pound just for two bus stops
and there was a one million three
hundred and five thousand pounds for
future home standards
um
i remember the interest and management
plan for baggage wood
um and i agree that there's no manage
there's no management plan in place at
the moment so i do think that's um a
step forward i don't agree entirely with
all the points made in that but when you
think that all our major consultants
have no objections
definitely council flood risk assessment
no objection natural england no ejection
environment agency no objection
environmental protection obviously no
objection and our own conservation
officer no objection
um
i'd after careful consideration i
consider that the benefits outweigh any
potential harm so i would recommend
that the application is improved
yeah i'll second that okay i totally
agree with council a lot
um
it was talked about the the management
of the wood um and but
the animals there now who pound the wood
the the floor of the wood down and
everything i understand about all that i
got enough farms where i live i
understand about that
but this is a far better scheme
uh to put forward as a management
scheme for this wood and i think it
would
totally benefit
um
the the situation with them so i'm
i'm i'm forward i was foreign
a few weeks ago and i'm for it now so
and the 44 the 44
affordable properties
for me are better than nothing because i
only see that every time
we have a side here
everybody's against the side so where do
we get where do we end up getting
affordable housing from them which we
need
and and so i'm sorry i i'm i'm for it
our second road roses
well the um application back in 2018
they spoke about
260 houses and they were offering them
23 affordable now they've increased it
to up to 290 but with only 15 affordable
so
something's changed in the interim
obviously for that
but i'll go back to what i said
originally it would be the destruction
of this site
as far as the ecology and biodiversity
and the badges etc and the bats that use
those headphones for foraging and flying
up and down
and not on reflecting to the chemist and
the rest of the scheme in the valley
there
it will be the destruction and again
development
in the most visually sensitive northwest
and west areas
as stated previously i consider the
vagisil wood should form the soft edge
between rural and urban land uses and
not the a39 road corridor
leaving this area undeveloped could also
bring additional benefits
including the extent of urban influences
of wildlife within badgers
hillwood and adjacent foraging areas
and recognizing that the noise and air
pollution from the nearby of a39 could
have adverse effects on future residents
living there so there are plenty of
reasons
i i'll read the reasons that i
would put down in the policy
reasons why i think we should be
refusing them
and i've started the first bit is the
site is located in open countryside and
by a reason of its distance from
town centre
is not considered to provide a
sustainable location
contrary to sto1
st07 with the north demon tourist local
plan
and paragraph 11 of the mpps
also the proposal which projects
development into the open countryside
is considered to have had this visual
impact on this part of benefit with the
loss of this green field summit
the site is visible from various
viewpoints and particularly from the a39
chemist biodomes
this would form a ribbon of development
from biddeford extending to the a39
highway it's therefore considered to
have an adverse impact on the character
and appearance of the open countryside
causing unacceptable harm to the
landscape
the proposal is considered to be
contrary to police policies sto1
st07 as the north generator's local plan
and paris 11 and 170 the mppf
and finally the proposal would require
the proposal requires a removal of a
significant plane to petrol along the
north side of its world together it's
creating public footpaths through the
ancient woodlands
rich in wildlife to protect its species
namely bats and badges which are present
in the badgers hill wood
the proposed residential layer of the
development would remove a wildlife
corridor which runs from the chemistry
nature reserve to the north through the
application side to the south
the proposal is therefore considered
contrary to pulses sdo4
st14
dm08 of the north terminator's local
and power 174 175 and 180 for the mppm
because of the lack of a five-year
housing land supply the balancing
process is triggered after careful
consideration of all aspects
of the application and using this
balancing process
it's considered the harm to the ecologic
biodiversity and protected species on
site on the wider area and the visual
impact on the wider area from
development of this site out by ways the
possible benefit of the proposal
and that's my reasons for recommending
that we refuse this
nobody else wants to speak it's been
proposed by myself secondly by
councillor craigie to refuse could you
take the vote please
that's the fountain
[Music]
again
[Music]
the application is refused for
thank you
[Music]
okay
right move on application 7
c
is on pages 88 to 102
in your report
eight slash twenty twenty one slash four
so this is a full application for the
change of use for a multi-use building
to a single holiday lapse including
external changes to be included in the
extent installation of windows and the
installation of a timber deck balcony to
support a micro wedding business
so there are no verbal updates to be
given to members members will recall
that there was a similar application
before members in october last year
and they also attended a previous batch
of site visits so they will be familiar
with the site
so just going on to the presentation
so this is a location plan with the
sunset building and rebuilding the
subject of the application
and the vehicle access to the east
outlined in red and the applicant's
other land ownership outlined in blue
the application site forms part of the
duck haven stud enterprise which is
located to the west of westford home
the site is run under the name westwood
living which offers 15 south asian
holiday let's and the site has also run
as an established budget venue since
2013. this aspect of the business is
related to this planning application
so the next slide is a block plan
so this shows the sunset rooms annotated
and planned out in red and memphis will
also see the ocean cave building to the
south west also orientation plan both
these buildings are used by the
applicant in connection with their
existing wedding business
the next slide is an aerial image of the
site sunset rooms has been annotated
with a red arrow
the site is a designated area
outstanding natural beauty and is
located in the coastal estuarine zone
a public graduate consisting of the
southwest coast path runs along the
western boundary of the site
so moving on to the proposal
as i said members have previously
attended a site visit and we'll be very
familiar with the buildings and the
surroundings
so this is a facial of the front
elevation of the sunset room
and the next specie shows the front
elevation
of the sunset room um taking slightly
further back into the site and show
members of the surrounding context and
the blue arrow indicates where the car
parking area is proposed to be used for
occupiers buildings
the next slide is another view of the
sunset room
building and members can see the
existing building has a large glaze
section to the front elevation and
enjoys views out to the sea
the next photo has been taken at the
front of the sunset rooms and
demonstrates the view out of the scene
the next phase shows a number of phases
just showing the interior of the sunset
rooms subject to the application as
members can see there is currently an
open plan functioning capable of taking
large events
so the next slide is just a context this
shows the ocean cave building which is
also used in connection with the wedding
business and has planning permission to
allow the building to be used for
holiday accommodation
so the next slide again is the context
showing the sunset buildings on the left
which is the subject of the application
and its relationship the ocean cave
building
um both of these buildings are used in
conjunction with that with the wedding
business
so this is the next phase from the
southwest coast past which borders the
western boundary of the site defenders
will recall a previously shown video
will be walking along the area of the
southwest coast path
to confirm that the existing building is
set back so the building is not visible
from that public right away
and the next slide is just another photo
which shows the private footwear which
leads up to the site from the southwest
coast path and again from this viewpoint
the sunset room building is not visible
so moving on to the proposal so the
proposal is for change of use of a
multi-use building to a single holiday
lecture with some external changes
which i will go into detail on so this
plan shows the existing and proposed
front and rear elevation of the sunset
rooms the drawing to the left is the
proposed and the drawing to the right of
the existing elevation
the proposed
external alterations include the
installation of a timber deck balcony
with non-perfect glass balustrading to
the front elevation and the external
staircase the side elevation to access
the balcony and there's also the
installation of five timber windows the
stained glass the southern
elevation which is shown to the left
bottom left there
the next slide is the existing and
proposed west elevation so the bottom
elevation shows the proposed spoken
area and the external sparring staircase
to access the balcony um the bottom
elevation does have measures annotated
on the plan
although they didn't come out very well
on the slide
so just to kind of confirm to members
that the existing building is 2.325
meters
the timber deck balcony is 0.67 meters
and the height of the balustrade is
shown as 1.1 meter
the agent has confirmed this is the
minimum requirement for building control
in terms of compliance so the overall
height of the building will increase
from 2.3 meters to 4.1 liters
the next slide
shows the eastern elevation showing the
installation of one stained glass window
and demonstrates the balcony area from
that side elevation
and the next slide shows the proposed
roof plan with it in the decking balcony
area and spiral staircase on
and the next slide is just an indicative
bedside view to demonstrate the proposed
timber jet
will recall
that previously there was not a real
balance trade and this has been added on
to the balcony area this time to ensure
there's no access to the roof
the next slide is the existing and
proposed floor plans of the sunset room
the floor plan to the left is the
existing and the full pound to the right
is the proposed the proposed alterations
include six bedrooms and a large dining
lounge area
so moving on just for briefly the
planning considerations
your officers would not wish to purchase
the continuation of the wedding business
being operated from the site
it
is the applicant's intention to continue
with the wedding business with a
slightly different business model from
large-scale weddings to micro weddings
to adjust to the market situation and
rebuild their business in light of the
phobia 19 panademic
it is clear that the ocean hay building
would need to function as a venue for
wedding ceremonies in the sunset room
for wedding practices and guest
accommodation
therefore members will see i have
recommended account edition which um
allows the ocean cave building to now
only be used for civil ceremonies and as
a wedding venue and the previous 29th
team commission to use the ocean cave as
holiday accommodation is effectively
swapped to allow the sunset room to be
used for holiday accommodation
in light of the uncertainties of created
19 pandemic and the adverse economic
impacts the wedding industry is because
this is considered a reasonable
compromise for a local business
so visual impact and landscape character
proposed external alterations have been
the outlined in the deck balconies to be
installed with non-reflective glass
so this would possibly allow keeping the
existing sunset buildings which members
would have seen primarily consist of
full-length blazing to the rear
elevation to the rear front elevation
the aov partnership has been consulted
as part of this application and members
will have read and see that they have
recommended a recommendation of refusal
of the application on the grounds of the
aomb partnership maintain a protection
percentage and state this a priority
it is recognised the author says that
the site is located in an extremely
sensitive location designated as an
error about finding natural beauty
the mppf gives great weight to
[Music]
and enhancing landscape and scenic
beauty such as the aomd
the officer considered that the composed
external changes to the host building
which is fully developed east of its
front elevation would not result in
material harm to the landscape of the
aomp
so impact on immunity any fair party
properties are located at distance so
there's no harm to the neighboring
immunities
highways the divine access statement
confirms there'll be less traffic
generation resulting from the proposal
is therefore considered a positive
improvement on the surrounding highway
network
drainage the foundry is to be dealt with
an existing environment and the
council's environmental protection
officer has raised no objections and he
has been um psychology has concluded
there's no effect on the protected
species as a result of this scheme
in conclusion the proposed changes use
and associated external changes is
considered acceptable contributing to
sustainable and social and economic
growth for the district subject to
appropriately worthy conditions it is
not considered the process of leaders
substantial harm to the designated
sensitive landscape
thank you jen
thank you tracy
but our first speaker against this is
the parish council
member claire davey pops
if you'd like to come up to the
microphone when you settle then give you
three minutes
to address the committee
[Music]
yeah
okay um
good morning i'm representing uh
paris council
and
uh planning policy states that the major
development in aonb should only be
committed where there's a proven
national interest and no alternative
site outside the
haven is a major development which has
grown from stable agricultural buildings
by small steps if a single application
had been submitted in the beginning
covering everything that has been
developed
that has since been developed it would
never have been approved
first the stables agricultural buildings
acceptable in an air and b followed by
greens accommodation
then we have the conversion of stables a
group of
accommodation two holiday leads from the
agricultural buildings have become
redundant
then the first approved normal
agricultural application was for ocean
caves as a wedding venue the sunset room
was then needed to make the ocean cave
business viable
with this application and another change
in use one wonders what the
application's attention will be going
forward
it would be useful to know what further
development is intended the omb aomb has
unsuccessfully called for an overall
plan for the duck hailing site
the application for change of use of the
sunset room two holiday competition is
designed to make the business viable
because large-scale effective weddings
at the moment are no longer held however
there will continue to be large weddings
and if there are large weddings past
experience suggests that there is every
possibility of a further application for
a sun-separated tight building to make
the business viable
the officers recommended recommendation
might seem straightforward because this
application is not requesting a new
building
in order to prevent further growth and
ensure continued local employment and
environment benefits conditions have
been proposed regarding the current
application
the committee needs to ask whether these
conditions are strong enough to stop the
sunset room being left as a holiday home
for the largest percentage of the year
and reducing the economic benefit to the
area with business
and the owners could be asked
to sign up to a long-term plan for the
site precluding further incremental
development
um duck haven has grown myself over a
long period of time it's become a large
development which should not have been
located in an airb
further approval could set a dangerous
precedent for other developers on this
basis i approve that the parish council
approves
opposes the application without stronger
conditions including any further
development and restricting the period
the room can be used as a holiday length
thank you thank you very much for your
presentation
our next speaker against the application
is philip barlow
apologies for virtue for this as a very
similar story
[Music]
you've got three minutes
as mentioned earlier we have a
biodiversity
catastrophe in the area
surveys of birds butterflies and bats
act like canaries in the coal mine
and they're indicating that we have
major declines
in the local
clifftop area there's been a
catastrophic decline in yellow hammer
house martin
stone chat white throat and meadow pivot
now many factors are involved
that are out with this area
but one that was within this area is
development and loss of habitat
the aonb should act as a buffer against
additional development
i've argued against developments in the
aonb for the last 20 years
especially with the a39 site and the
growth of the duckhaven site
neither site should have been granted
approval within the aonb
[Music]
the last 12 months has seen a welcome
improvement in the habit act on the aon
b stretch from westwood ho to
cleveland with a lot of hedge planting
head restoration
flower meadow restoration and tree
planting
however in the case of duckhaven the one
the record is one of substantial
development by stealth
but little apparent work to improve the
diverse biodiversity of the site
this new application offers no
mitigation
and the green credentials appear to be
driven by marketing concerns rather than
the environment
furthermore as pointed out in the aonb
submission there are works required
which are not included in this
application
i oppose this change of use and let us
set unless a set of conditions are
proposed and enforced that will stop
further building
within the aomb
and i would suggest they should also
include significant environmental
improvements to increase biodiversity on
the site
made it this time
right our next speaker in support i
don't know if there is cattle murder
not coming
so our next speaker name is mr alan
smith in
[Music]
just support them
[Music]
[Music]
this application
is exactly the same as the application
we received a month or two ago
with the exception
that we haven't got the
likes we haven't got the skylines
without application the chairman said he
would vote in favor if it wasn't for the
skylines
we'd listen to the chairman
we listen to everybody and we remove the
skylights
so we
basically produce what you want
[Music]
a lot of opportunities spoken by mardu
about the uh what we've done up there or
not done to
rnc
aomb
in his
statement he made
in sports which he spent
he trespassed on our line and took
photographs
mr smith
we don't want anything personal
speak speak about the application
[Music]
very kindly he said one of the
photographs
showed how
the aom should look like
i agree with the retirement that
photograph is of our land and what we've
done on the area
the second photograph showed
the
um sunset rooms
the land behind the sunset rooms you'll
notice is all covered in doors and all
sorts of shrubbery because we spend a
lot of money encouraging wildlife down
diverted the corridor
across from
normative land to westwood home
complete without what we've done there
wouldn't be a car
the land in front of us is shown on this
planet
has all been um planted with um
what we call it
[Music]
flower things
we spent an awful lot of money because
the whole thing what we're doing down
there is to do with conservation
[Music]
um
you mr german will write this
[Music]
going to be 11 there's not 12 there are
12 but two spots across each other
so you wouldn't notice that but there
are four champions and they are designed
to be more likely to accommodate more
than
living accommodation
[Music]
no other reason
so
we take away the light
help you
all right
thanks thank you mr smith thank you
so much
you do that
[Music]
[Music]
right thank you and our final speak with
more member cancer for repentance
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chair thank you for allowing
me to speak at this meeting it seems
times gone very quickly from the 7th of
october last year so
we're back here again
some lots of the applications coming
back again it seems like but there we go
um just a special history from my point
of view i've been on participatory
elected four times now since 2007 but
i've only been more member for abbotsham
since 2019 so when you look at the pages
of
applications that are there before you
page 88 through it's only the last four
applications that i've actually followed
through
i'm not going to say it all because i
think
you've heard the argument so many times
and there's one there are some changes
to bring this new application back
um
situation is quite simple from my point
of view sustainable development you've
talked about it a lot this morning
there's three sides to economic social
and environmental
and
you have to look at it from each
application in its own unique situation
here
the building is already there is a
change of use of the existing building
and i get concerned because last night i
was listening to news about leveling up
in our national economy and if we don't
get it right for our own local economy
in our planning department and allow
businesses to develop appropriately
then i think we're going to
make mistakes on our own behalf without
any further help coming from central
government we'd have to put our own
house in order in the first place
the economic argument is clear from the
point of view the application any owner
of a building
if they're inside the aonb should have
the right to apply
and go through the due process of
pulling against north devon and torres
local plan
and this has been done the economic
argument
is for the business owner to work out
their own economic development from that
point of view and you have to trust
businesses to maximize and i understand
this business will not only benefit
itself but it brings in other businesses
of quality providers so there is an
economic multiplier that comes through
the situation here from that point of
view
the social side of the uh
sustainable development is very much met
in in the area that
i see traffic will be less so therefore
there was
even an argument that the environmental
is improved because of less traffic
going through the area so i would
encourage you to look at the application
and the uniqueness of the situation i
have a lot of sympathy with philip
morrow and
miss scott mrs fox and their comments
but i feel on the balance of planning on
the balance of planning between social
environmental and economic i think there
is a strong argument here in this
specific situation the uniqueness is the
application
that this should be approved my ass
committee to approve this application
thank you chair
thank you counselor
right that concludes
the speakers and
this application
i'll just mention that
it is
a
change of views from a multi-use
building to a single holiday net not a
hotel single holiday there anyway i
don't need to debate you'd like to start
yeah um i agree with that
with what you just said which is quite
funny for me to agree with you but
um
the thing is with it is that it's
already there
now
you know we
looked to me and so we're trying to say
that
this shouldn't be approved because
it's it's kind of a new building well
it's not a new build
and the last time
it was here we did not like the roof
lights which they got rid of
uh i see they put the balustrade up at
the back of the
um the
the
roof the roof terrace
um
i
for one feel that
we should approve this
so
i'm going to
propose that we approve it because for
the simple reason it is there
it is nothing new all it is is a change
of use and i think
um i think
we should approve it
all right thank you councillor watson
council a lot
yeah i mean going back to when this
first came before us i think that was
the only council that actually supported
the application and i'm glad to see that
they've got
um
[Music]
i would still like to see you know i
still like to see a condition
and i think i answered it last time
that no street furniture will be
situated on that roof
whether it's permanent or taken up by a
visitor i don't think there should be
any tables of chairs whatsoever up on
that balcony
so i don't know if that would be able to
be conditioned
yeah i think that's something we can
condition um to ensure that there is no
um
furniture or street furniture um
um
i think that could be added to the
recommendation i think that's what i
said last time
into it as a condition i would i would
only add what reason
[Music]
well because it would encourage people
to sit on there and they might add
lanterns up there and things like that
and candles on the table and that would
you know detract from having taken away
the roof lines
right okay
so i will second cancer what's uh
watson's approval motion with that
additional
condition
counselor christian yes um well i called
this in originally
and i think my calling still stands uh i
know the roof light's been removed but
that wasn't the reason i called it in
the first place
uh what what we've got here
is basically
a facility that is used intermittently
a holiday let could be used all year and
we could have the lights coming out of
those huge glass fronts all year round
um i know it was a slip of the tongue
but it's slightly worrying to
hear it called a hotel
rather than a holiday there they are
very different things
um i know what the aboriginal council
has said and
it was a wonderful phrase i thought duck
haven had grown by stealth
and it has and we all know that um the
reason i called it in you'll see why two
reasons are there about the
intermittency and the comments by the
aomb now the previous application you
were discussing somebody made the point
that all the statutory bodies were in
favor here they're not
and the amb is a very important
statutory body in this case
um
the two parish councils are against it
and i was surprised here councillor
pennington to delegate his own parish
councils that's up to him um they were
against it and i thought they were
getting some very good grounds
when this building was first built i
understood it it was only it only got
planning because it was integral to the
wedding business
i now understand that the cave is still
going to keep going
uh this will be used for weddings but
it'll also be used for holiday let's
um
so it's not it's become even more
multi-use as far as i can see
and i'm afraid i'm going to vote against
it it's all very well saying it's
already there
but there is a fairly major change in
how it's going to be used in this case
and i think that is the reason for
turning it down thank you
thank you anybody else want to speak
cancer no i just questioned what
counselor prison said
and ask the officers because you can't
you can't get married in this building
so it's just purely the holiday yeah so
the context is that the ocean cave
building is has planning vision for
hyundai left so effectively what my
conditions recommend is that the ocean
cable goes back to a place where you can
get married and the sunset rooms then
act as the guest accommodation to
sweating practices
yeah so thank you so much from yeah
in this
[Music]
it was the roof lights because of a very
large when we had the application
before
uh last time they were very large that
were going to be set into that roof and
the light spilled from those was the
issue
plus i think it was cancelled boxing
raised
um
fencing along the rear of that balcony
so people couldn't be running about on
that route
um
i personally don't think
i'm not concerned whether the chambers
and chairs are there enough to be honest
because
the building is there now if people are
stood there
i don't see why they shouldn't be sat
there they can still be up there with
torches or lights with candles i really
think it's not necessary to put that
condition but that's what council a lot
to ask for
and
the other thing when it was first
brought to us from making concern was
looking back up to it from the coastal
path
and tracy told us that it's not visible
of course now there is a balcony
so for me i've got no objection the
building's already there
whether it's by stealth but it's things
do change buildings are used for various
things
and this is an application to journalism
the fact that people have said
if it wasn't there it was applied for as
a holiday probably wouldn't get
[Music]
i've got no objections to this
application
as it stands
um could you take the vote please with
that condition
can i just check that cancer watson is
happy with that yes i am yeah and check
i just checked out we delegate the
wording and that condition to officers
[Music]
four
[Music]
counselor christie again
that's a crazy
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank tracy
right we'll move on with the agenda
that's the end of the planning
applications the president of the
generous reveals decision summary on
pages 103 207.
you see that
feelings
item
nine is possible not possible in any
appeals
item ten on the agenda
the delegated decisions that agm
applications on pages underneath there
yeah
item
item 11 on pages 109
to 117
are the
list of planning decisions
between the 21st
of uh december last year and the 19th
of january this year
start to change
109
110
11
111 quicker quicker 112
113
[Music]
117
[Music]
and that's the management plans the
environmental management plans
um we see them quite regularly don't we
on major applications and it's in our
potential condition
all right so what is this
manager
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
on
youtube you spoke with the application
thank you